all of a sudden he sees me trying to
stab his mom like it's not good
[Music]
hey everybody i'm brad williams i'm here
to answer the internet
would you rather wake up to a [ __ ] or
a hundred dollars under your pillow
every morning in my single days
definitely [ __ ] even my married days
before a kid blow job uh but now that i
got a kid 100 bucks college fun diapers
aren't cheap yeah i would do that for
sure what tv show could you take a
college course on and get an a south
park i've seen every episode multiple
times it's a
it's comedy genius it's filthy comedy
but at the same time really smart
intelligent comedy they still get away
with stuff matt and trey are geniuses
what i'm trying to say is get me on
south park
should you lock a dog out of the room
when you're having sex
yes
absolutely also i have a 70 pound pit
bull if we don't lock him out of the
room it's no longer a twosome okay he
gets involved all of a sudden he sees me
trying to stab his mom like it's not
good i get a wet nose places yes lock
your dog out of the out it's don't don't
your dog doesn't want to see that
if you got a one-time pass do whatever
you wanted what crime would you commit i
wouldn't do murder
i don't wanna
yeah
i think probably robbery what if i was
like just really innocent i was like
loitering
i would loiter
you know what i could do if i if i
couldn't get arrested i'd i'd squat
i do squatting and someone's like
[ __ ] amazing house apart you know
what i'd go to the presidente's house
and squat there because i imagine it's
pretty cool
if you had to get one movie quote
tattooed on your body
what would it be it would be the joker
quote
uh from
uh batman
if you're good at something never do it
for free
by the way uh i have my invoice for you
later for doing this
would you rather give up porn or sex for
one year uh i'm married with a
two-year-old and practically giving up
sex uh for the last year uh with the
two-year-old and the 70-pound pit ball
uh so yeah i i would rather give up sex
and have my porn it's my escape
if you had to have a theme song play
every time you arrived somewhere what
would it be it would be the theme from
batman the animated series that was a
good one
yeah i like batman it's my favorite one
i want to be a rich guy have toys
okay
wow
all right um
you know what just
this is what he hands me i don't know
what these questions are i don't know
what they're gonna be and i'm just like
reading but this is what he hands me
tell me tell me if this is in focus it's
just a card with a kkk member on it
that's what he hands me
and like i'm just supposed to look at
that like yeah yeah that's nothing i
just gotta
take it i i don't know what this says
all i see is the kkk member and i'm like
that is not gonna be good
oh man uh so the question
is can you still go to your barber if he
is very racist
i mean the question is how good is the
barber
all right
like oh and oh man you know what
probably not if it's very racist like i
like i can do i can go to a barber if
he's very good and casually racist
cali
casually racist is a little different if
if like like if the barber says stuff
like nah i don't go to that side of town
because you know those kinds of people
live there i'm like all right i can deal
with that like that's
that's a little bit of racism where i'm
like i'm good like but if he's straight
up if he's cutting my hair in the kkk
outfit
and like just saying the n-word and
other slurs i'd be like nah
i'll go
there's a super cuts down the street i'm
a dude i don't have anything complicated
up there i'm very simple so yeah uh i
could go if they were casually racist
but very racist no i couldn't do that
if you're watching on youtube click here
to subscribe so you get all the new
episodes as they come out and john what
should they click if they want
notifications
make sure you click thumbs up for the
like hit that bell icon